So now that we've discussed the idea Trump
floated of leaving the country, if he loses
to Joe Biden.
Let's get to the really authoritarian stuff
from Trump's last few rallies.
Now, I know I know what's more authoritarian
than Trump threatening to do what many dictators
have done, which is flee their country when
they lose their grip on power.
But Trump did something even more dystopian
at some recent rallies over the weekend.
He again insisted that he would lock up the
Bidens.
And remember that Donald Trump vowed to lock
up Hillary Clinton back in 2016.
Lately, Trump has been saying Obama and Biden
committed the greatest political crime in
the history of the United States against me.
And yet he hasn't been able to actually name
a single law that was broken.
But it's now taken on an even uglier tone.
Trump is straight up saying the Bidens should
be jailed.
Take a look.
I'm telling you that Biden family and others,
but that Biden family is corrupt, is a corrupt
family.
And with me and my kids and my kids, I'll
tell you something that just lock them up.
You shouldn't lock them up.
Lock up the lock up, Hillary.
This is outrageous authoritarianism.
This is a nightmare and it has become normalized.
Many of us don't even react anymore.
Trump, basking during this event in big CNN
sucks.
Chance you see many people not even wearing
masks and Trump directing the crowd's anger
against the media in the back.
As Trump often points to 10 million dead.
Please.
Had a great father.
I'm not just running against Biden in that
corrupt family.
I'm running against the leftwing corrupt media.
And we're running against Big Daddy.
The authoritarianism continued all weekend,
Trump doing these now daily, sometimes two,
even three of these in a day, continued the
next day in Michigan at a similar rally.
Before we continue with the authoritarianism,
a brief interlude.
Trump still struggling to speak here, very
powerfully, struggling with the name Christopher
Columbus.
Take a look.
If you're Italian, do you happen to like Christoph
or Columbus Christophe four?
OK, so back to the authoritarianism.
Trump says lock them all up as his sycophants
chant, lock her up about Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer.
Remember, she was recently the victim of a
foiled or the potential victim.
She was the target and potential victim of
a kidnaping plot hatched up by some Q and
on Trump ists.
And they want to lock them all up.
I mean, what you're doing in Michigan has
been amazing.
Now you've got to get your governor to open
up your state.
And get your schools open, get your schools
open, the schools have to be open.
Right.
Lock them all up.
That's an idea that doesn't seem to account
for due process, does it?
And this just continues.
The crowd wants everybody locked up.
It's a mob of people demanding the imprisonment
of individuals not charged with and in some
cases not even wildly suspected of any crimes.
For the second time in a single speech, Trump
fans chanting, lock her up about Gretchen
Whitmer.
That's right.
She's doing it for everybody is locked down
except my husband.
He could go sailing anytime.
A guy like Biden and the Democrats want to
keep Michigan locked up, locked down and closed
for business.
No, it's so badly hurting your state.
It is reminiscent of Mussolini, just mango
colored.
That's the different.
It's tangerine colored.
That's the difference between Mussolini and
the stuff that we are seeing right here.
And Trump, of course, responding to chants
of lock her up by saying, are we having a
good time?
This was about Hillary Clinton.
Now they want to erase the name of Clinton.
That'll be next to.
Crooked Hillary will take.
Does he ever name it?
I don't know if she's got her name on anything.
If she does, I'm all for.
Take it down.
Drink it.
Are we having a good time so.
Yeah, that's very, very ugly and aggressive
stuff that is just normal at these Trump rallies.
Trump then again with this stuff about maybe
we'll be here for more years, maybe we go
an extra four.
And I'm gonna make a point here that is more
about Trump's fans than what Trump says himself.
We'll be here for four years and then if we
decide to go for an extra four or eight.
Well, I think 12 is going to be now the gold
standard.
That'll be that'll be the new chair.
So people like to argue, like when Trump talks
about eight more years.
Twelve more years.
Is Trump kidding?
Is he just trying to trigger to the left?
That's not the primary issue to me.
Trump is just one guy.
The real issue to me is that the crowd cheers
for it.
Trump joking about trying to seize power beyond
what is constitutionally allowed and to be,
you know, get a third term, a fourth term,
whatever.
OK, it's wacky.
Maybe it's a joke.
Maybe it's not.
The fact that the crowd cheers is the nightmare.
If you like this stuff.
You are an authoritarian.
Whether Trump means it seriously or not.
And that's where I believe our focus on this
should remain.